ذروه تصعيد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمستوطنين ضد المناطق الفلسطينيه في
الساعات الثمانيه والاربعين الماضيه سجلت
في بلده حواره وعدد من قرى نابلس وهو
الهجوم الاكبر من نوعه ضد هذه المنطقه منذ
سنوات حيث اسفر عن مقتل فلسطينيين واصابه
عشرات واحراق وتدمير عشرات المنازل
والسيارات الفلسطينيه وذلك بعد مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين في اطلاق نار على سياره
كان يستقلانها قرب هذه البلده ومساء امس
الاثنين قتل اسرائيلي متاثرا بجراح خطيره
اصيب بها لدى اطلاق النار على سيارته قربه
اريحا اعقبه فرض جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
حصارا على المدينه في محاوله لاعتقالها
المنفذين وهي تطورات الدفعات وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوقاف جالانت الى توقعى ان
تشهد الفتره المقبله اياما معقده وصعبه
وعلى هذا الاساس امر الوزير الاسرائيلي
بتعزيز قواته في الضفه الغربيه بكتيبه
رابعه بعد تقييم الوضع الامنيين هناك
معنا الان من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديريج الجبال ضعيف في اخر
تطورات هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي والاجراءات
الاسرائيليه خصوصا نسيمه وان هناك المزيد
من التصريحات التي تحدث عن استخدام المزيد
من القوه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
سنبدا ايمان ببيان مقتضب للجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي اعلن بان الكتيبه ستقوم بمناوره
عسكريه يوم غد في الضفه الغربيه لم نفهم
هل نتحدث عن اربع كتائب هي التي تم ضخها
في الضفه الغربيه ام عن كتيبه واحده وما
شكل هذه المناورات ان كان يتم استباحه
الضفه الغربيه بالكامل والقدس المحتله
واصبحت الان تحت سيطره الاحتلال ولكن وفق
ما كل ما ذكرتيه ايمان ما رايناه بالامس
تحديدا في بلده حواره واضح ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ادرك انه قبل يوم امس فقد
السيطره في بلده حواره كانت الارض بالكامل
للمستوطنين الحرق التدمير
الاشعال المنازل الحرائق التي لم يتمكن
احد من اطفائها لساعات طويله زادت من حده
التوتر الداخلي حتى داخل اسرائيل من الذي
واي وزير هو من يقرر في الضفه الغربيه
وهذا ما كان عليه الحال في السابق لدى
تشكيل هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولكن على
الارض الوضع الميداني نتحدث عن ثلاثه ايام
من حصار مشدد على بلده حواره ولكن اليوم
عندما زار ممثل الخاص الامريكي لشؤون
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هادي عامر كان لافت
لاول مره لهجه تصعيديه وغاضبه اتجاه
اسرائيل حيث وصف ما حدث في حواره بان
هجمات شنيعه وغير مقبوله ويجب محاسبه
ومقاضات المسؤولين عن ذلك هذا لم نراه منذ
سنوات طوال ولكن هذا الحديث والزياره جاءت
بعد لقاء هادي عامر مع مين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير حسين الشيخ لان
الجميع ادرك الان ويبدو انه واضح للجميع
ان الامور بدات تفلت في الميدان وان
اجتماع العقبه نسفته اسرائيل بدايه
بمجزره نابلس الاربعاء الماضي وما تلاها
وما حدث في حوار ايضا في منطقه اريحا لا
زال الحصار متواصل لليوم الثاني على
التوالي ولا ننسى ان هنا فقط نذكر ان
اريحا هي ايضا
الطريق الى العالم الخارجي هي الطريق التي
توصل الفلسطينيين عبر الاردن الى العالم
الخارجي والتمكن من السفر
ازمات مروريه خانقه لاحد يستطيع الدخول او
الخروج وحتى الان قوات الاحتلال بكل
ازرعها الامنيه والعسكريه
والاستخباريه لم تستطع الوصول سواء الى من
نفذوا الهجوم المسلح في حواره او في اريحا
والمقلق لدى اسرائيل الان ان العمليات
كلها فرديه لا وتقف وراءها اي تنظيمات
وهذا ما يزيد التوتر الا لدى ايضا الجانب
الاسرائيلي ولكن على الارض يبقى الوضع
متوتر في كل الاراضي الفلس طينيه
من رام الله